josh gordon has been suspended many
times during his nfl career and the
latest came yesterday out of the blue
josh gordon suspended indefinitely for
his latest violation possibly violations
of the substance abuse policy and this
time around a ped policy violation which
typically is a minimum of four games the
substance abuse policy we don't know how
long it'll last it has been various
times for josh gordon that he has been
suspended when he's played he's played
well in 2013 chris his second season in
the nfl in only 14 games he generated
more receiving yardage than terrell
owens or randy moss ever did in any
season in their entire career yeah
that's how good he could have been and
it's it's
sad it's unfortunate the nfl shouldn't
care about guys smoking marijuana on
their own time especially when they are
away from the job site for months but
the nfl does these are the rules and if
you don't comply you don't play and it's
just a shame that it's happened to
anyone really but it's a shame that has
happened to a guy who was so talented
remember he came in the same year as
justin blackman right blackman washed
out early due to similar reasons and uh
i think that's one of the reasons why
the nfl is softening this
the stigma for marijuana obviously has
completely changed it's not there like
it used to be
and i think the nfl realizes why why are
we being sticklers on this rule that is
keeping great players off the field we
want great players to play football
right yeah i agreed and i mean you know
we're seeing health benefits from cbd or
marijuana and things for helping guys
that way uh i i gotta think though this
is the end of the road for josh gordon
you know and and like to what you're
saying it's one of the freakier athletes
ever we've ever seen mike i i saw him in
training camp his second year i think it
was in the nfl i was down in cleveland
he came out on the field and i couldn't
believe it he was one of those guys that
makes your jaws drop because you go oh
my gosh this guy's a receiver i mean yes
six four muscles popping out everywhere
you know
big square shoulders like he's lebron
james uh just the perfect specimen and
yeah it's been a lot of issues mike and
you know the one thing i'll say and i
don't you know this is just rumors i
hear i just hope it hasn't gotten more
to marijuana okay that's and again i
don't know that for sure but i know
there's rumors around the nfl that it
might have
slipped into some some
other things to go along with it and i
just hope that's not true and i hope he
can just get his life let's let's let's
be careful because those are numbers we
don't want to be trafficking
and there has been this persistent sense
that maybe it's other substances under
the substance abuse policy but i look at
it this way right i don't care what it
is if it's not a ped right the nfl is a
seasonal job and i know that in the off
season
there are guys who are working and they
have a much more extensive program than
they did years ago but these are
temporary ideally four month a year five
six month a year workers the rest of the
time they're on their own why does the
nfl why has the nfl compelled for all
these years to police their private
lives if they're not out endangering
someone if they're not driving their
vehicle while they're under the interior
yeah right in the privacy of their own
home
why does the nfl care and that has
always bothered me uh and this is a this
is a problem in various other industries
as well off-duty
behavior
by an employee why and when
should an employer care about it i think
the nfl has gone too far and hopefully
at some point that pendulum will swing
the other way yeah i hope so too to me
it is i mean i mean you're right first
off i would like to only see people you
know get reprimanded or go into the drug
program if they like you said driving
under the influence you know been caught
with illegal substances that way but you
know to test guys and do all that i
think it is ridiculous gosh we got way
more important jobs in our country uh
where people don't get as strictly
tested with some of this stuff and we
trust those people to do jobs on a
day-in day-out basis but yet football
you know for some reason we're going to
be really strict with that and let alone
we talk about you know the publicizing
of alcohol and liquor which is killing
millions of people uh and you know there
you go you just get into the instance of
weed it makes people what sit on the
couch and eat a bag of chips uh or eat
some m ms i mean that's about as bad as
it ever gets from that standpoint and
and i'm with you i think it hurts the
league and and it also drives guys to
times to go into opioids and that's an
issue and i know i've had you know two
teammates in my past who have had issues
with that because of the drug program
and it's it's you know
taking their life for a bad turn
josh gordon had seven catches in five
games with the seahawks just last week
pete carroll explained that they needed
to do a better job of getting in the
ball he had a spectacular 58-yard
reception against the panthers on sunday
caught the back of the ball pulled it in
that may be the last catch we ever see
him make in the nfl and where do the
seahawks go from here yeah chris at the
receiver position doug baldwin retired
tyler lockett kind of stepped into that
role d.k metcalf has done well but there
was that euphoria when they got josh
gordon and he and i guess it's better
for the seahawks that he didn't have
like three or 450 yard games because
then they would really be feeling this
he didn't do enough from a production
standpoint that they're going to feel
rattled and shell shocked by this but
what do they do at receiver without him
well i mean they you know dk metcalf and
lockett are the go-to guys and lock it
just getting healthy after having that
leg bruise or whatever he was dealing
with there so that's plenty to go around
and then you know when you talk about
you know uh you know
they got david moore still on the roster
you know 17 i always forget his damn
name uh malik turner they got other
go-to targets that way so you're right
it's not going to be like a a huge oh my
gosh we don't have josh gordon that's a
staple of our offense no dk metcalf kind
of fills the role of what josh gordon
was uh as far as specimen down the field
target big guy you can throw jump balls
to big guys you can throw short passes
to and expecting to break a tackle and
make yards after the catch that way so
it's not a huge blow to their overall
attack of what they want to do on the
offensive side of the ball
hey and you know what remember when the
seahawks claimed josh gordon on waivers
after the patriots let him go and we all
kind of thought boy the patriots must
most something's up that's why they left
do you think they do do you think they
did do you think they knew this was
coming i have a feeling that the
behaviors they saw at work translated
that's right i would think too right yes
consider this though the other report at
the time was that the seahawks were
looking at antonio brown and i know
teams are staying away from him because
of the possibility he would be put on
paid leave but he here's the thing
there's only two games left in the
regular season right
does somebody sign him
and risk paying him for one game
that he wouldn't be allowed to play in
if they do put him on the commissioner
example list wouldn't it be weird if
after all these months and the nfl
hasn't done anything with him you know
maybe a team forces the nfl's hand
wouldn't the ceo wouldn't it be great
for the seahawks to say hey we're
signing antonio brown we're going to
force you to put him on the commissioner
exempt list and if you don't we got
antonio brown for the playoffs yeah i
mean that it makes sense but the risk is
antonio brown who the hell knows what he
does when he's on your roster for the
playoffs good point we'll be right back
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports